Він двічі підкорив Говерлу…
Прожив три місяці в Індонезії…
Пірнав на дно океану й катався на екстремальних атракціонах.
І все це з пересадженим серцем.
Складно повірити, але ще сім років тому Максим Греков був за крок до смерті.
Лише трансплантація подарувала йому друге життя.
Почитав хто як живе після пересадки, попрощався з баскетболом, із спортом, із горами, з дайвінгом, з усім.
За три роки після пересадки я встиг зробити все це. Насправді я сам себе здивував.
Щороку в Україні потребують трансплантації близько 5 тисяч людей,
але більш як половина з них помирає, так і не дочекавшись операції.
А змінити цю статистику - можна.
Всього одна заява, на заповнення якої йде до десяти хвилин, у майбутньому здатна врятувати до п’яти життів.
Ідеться про згоду на посмертне донорство.
Її, приміром, вже підписала українська ведуча й громадська активістка Ярослава Кравченко.
Кілька років тому актор Андрій Панас раптово загинув,
і після його смерті дружина дала дозвіл на трансплантацію.
І він врятував своїми органами трьох чи чотирьох людей, яким їх пересадили.
І мене так тоді ця історія зачепила.
І я подумала, що треба дізнатися, треба дізнатися.
Якийсь час ішов, а сьогодні, коли ти розумієш, що смерть більш вірогідна
- особливо, якщо ти залишаєшся весь час в Україні,
то хотілося, щоб вона була не марною й могла допомогти.
Про своє рішення Ярослава написала у соцмерeжах на багатотисячну аудиторію.
Деяких підписників приклад ведучої надихнув, а ось її маму спочатку налякав.
Моя мама дуже злякалася, тому що вона побачила сторіз і тільки слово "транспантація".
Я сиджу в Амосова, в мене розривається телефон: "Ясю, що за трансплантація?".
Я кажу: "Мамо, зачекай. Потім розкажу".
Мені 5 людей з моїх підписників відписалися, що вони теж пішли й теж надали згоду.
Мені здається, що це дуже крутий результат.
І це справді так. Для прикладу, у центрі трансплантації на базі лікарні "Феофанія"
- за три роки - було зареєстровано лише три пожиттєві згоди.
Дві з них - від медиків. У масштабах багатомільйонного Києва - це, по суті, ніщо.
Ми покриваємо, може, 5-7% від потреби.
Це кількість донорів у відношенні до кількості реципієнтів, які знаходяться в списках очікування.
Нема донорів, нема донорських органів, які б дозволили нам виконати необхідну кількість трансплантацій.
Частково це наслідок великої кількості міфів і упереджень щодо донорства, особливо, посмертного.
Ходять такі міфи, що ти зараз підпишеш і тебе в підворотнях,
в темному кутку вб'ють й розберуть на органи.
Але тоді це має бути, ну якщо фантастично так уявити:
банда кваліфікованих хірургів-трансплантологів, які чатують на тебе в підворотні.
У реальному житті нелегальна пересадка - це, по суті, смертельний вирок, і ось чому…
Окрім співпадіння за групою крові, нам треба ще провести ряд імунологічних тестів,
які покажуть нам, що у разі пересадки органа, організм не відторгне цей орган миттєво.
Це достатньо складний і дороговартісний процес,
який наразі чисто технічно можна зробити в 2-3 клініках по всій країні загалом.
Необхідні спеціалісти, які це зроблять. Не так багато спеціалістів можуть це зробити якісно.
Потрібні надзвичайно стерильні умови, в яких це буде зроблено.
Тому що якщо під час трансплантації відбувається інфікування органу
- це майже 100% призведе до смерті реципієнта.
Навіть якщо людина дає згоду на посмертне донорство за життя
- це не означає, що її органи комусь і колись пересадять.
Має співпасти чимало чинників.
Насамперед важливі обставини смерті. Переважно донорами стають після інсультів.
Тоді мозок людини помирає, але медикам ще якийсь час вдається штучно підтримувати життєдіяльність органів.
Лікарі зробили все, що могли, для того, щоб врятувати життя.
І лише після цього ми починаємо думати, а чи може ця людина бути донором.
Спілкуватися з родичами, дивитися в електронній інформаційній системі,
чи давала ця людина за життя згоду на посмертну донацію.
Також накласти вето на донорство можуть родичі.
Навіть якщо померлий давав пожиттєву згоду.
Люди, напевно, не вірять, що таке відбулося.
Що їхній родич помер. Вони, може, вважають, що якість меддопомоги,
яка надавалась, недостатня і можна ще щось зробити.
І людина, яка немає відношення до медицини, може вважати, що родич ще живий,
в нього ж ще працюють нирки, легені, серце - то він живий, як це так?
У 2022-му кількість трансплантацій в Україні зросла на 20%.
Але це ніяк не пов'язано з війною.
За законом, військові та цивільні, чия смерть настала внаслідок бойових дій, донорами не можуть ставати.
Ні військовий, ні цивільний не розглядаються.
Люди стають донорами за тих самих обставин, якщо б війни не було.
Закордонні колеги часто мене питали, зараз вже перестали: скажіть, а чому?
У вас зараз може різко збільшитися кількість донацій анатомічних матеріалів.
Але з огляду на ось цю етичну складову і на ті речі, які не повністю зрозумілі закордонному фахівцю.
Тому що вони не проходять через це, вони це не переживають.
В Україні було прийняте рішення не змінювати нормативні документи.
Особисті дані українців, які дали згоду на посмертне донорство,
надійно захищені, переконують у Центрі трансплант-координації.
До моменту настання смерті інформація з єдиної електронної системи
трансплантації органів засекречена для всіх.
Електронна система здоров'я ІХелс про згоду за життя теж нічого не знає.
Технічно, фізично. Тобто жоден лікар інших галузей і навіть трансплантологи
не можуть з'ясувати, чи давав Петренко чи Сидоренко згоду чи не давав.
Це до розвінчання міфу про те, що якщо я дам згоду, то за мною почнеться полювання,
і десь на зупинці мене… для того, щоб я став донором.
Такого бути не може.
Чим більше українці позбуватимуться своїх упереджень, тим частіше ставатимуться історії порятунку.
Восени 2022 року був випадок, коли мама померлого самостійно звернулася до лікарів про те,
що вона б хотіла, щоби її син врятував інші життя.
З дотриманням всіх етичних складових відбулося вилучення цих анатомічних матеріалів,
які потім роз'їхалися по різних лікарнях.
Було врятовано дві дитини і двоє дорослих.
І якби не донорське серце, не було врятовано Максима Грекова.
У 2015 році під час підготовки до операції з видалення апендициту
в Максима виявили серйозні відхилення в роботі серця.
До того моменту я у лікарні був, може, у зубного кілька разів.
За 32 роки. Тобто у мене жодних проблем не було зі здоров'ям.
Я дуже здивувався. Я навіть не знав, що таке аспірин і навіщо він потрібен.
Назву діагнозу я кілька днів вивчав: дилатаційна кардіоміопатія.
Ані у мого батька не було проблем із серцем, ані у мого діда.
Це просто може статися будь з ким і будь-коли і ніхто від цього не застрахований, на жаль.
Після успішної пересадки серця у 2016-му - Максим почав друге життя: нове й насичене.
Я роблю більше, ніж робив до цього.
Тому що до цього ти завжди думаєш, що є завтра та післязавтра.
А зараз розумієш, що ні.
Олімпійський рекорд я вже не поставлю точно, тому що серце дає десь 70% від того, що давало мені моє перше.
Але для того, щоб грати на вулиці в баскетбол, мені достатньо.
Пересаджене серце - це пожиттєва інвалідність.
А значить - дозвіл виїжджати за кордон в умовах війни.
Тож для Максима це додаткова можливість допомогти ЗСУ.
Я знятий з військового обліку. Через це я можу спокійно заїжджати й виїжджати в країну.
Власне, тому хлопці, хто що міг поскидувалися, є знайомі в Данії, вони взяли тачку.
Я зганяв за однією машиною. Потім я ще з Болгарії одну машину до цього гнав,
тому що я можу це зробити.
Так що є якісь плюси в інвалідності.
Саме чиєсь рішення про посмертне донорство врятувало Максиму життя.
Тож сьогодні він розповідає свою історію, аби надихнути українців не боятися
давати пожиттєву згоду на посмертне донорство.